awesome yo we're live again alright
let's do this let me just Twitterverse
this and we'll get right back into it
technical difficulties have been
conquered that's how you spell that
come join me live alright guys we're
gonna get right back into it here
guarantee it
I just gotta find the link to the video
just like it share it a little bit here
we go
we're goin again guys isn't that just
great Thank You Quincey
cool all right I'm gonna give give it a
few minutes just so I can get some
people in here and then I'm gonna get
right back into coding because this has
been quite a bit of technical
difficulties we gotta mix up hardware we
got some software I needed to you know
fix some settings and things but now
we're totally rockin it right I'm gonna
do a little pop out the chat and then
I'll knock you away you cool got that
there all right well so hello again to
anyone who has joined us again had to
two hours later but rockin and rollin
I'm gonna go for a little bit longer
until basically we get through as much
as we can um so yeah to get right back
into it uh I'm gonna restart the my dev
tools here so we got the we've got
MongoDB running which is where all the
challenges are stored and then we're
gonna go back over to the gulp profile
run gulp so we have that thing building
and then to give a brief overview of
what we're all looking at I have yeah my
vs code editor which is running a
terminal inside of it which is really
awesome the code is right here for the
es6 challenges then I have the github
account on my github that I use to track
my changes as well as the actual website
you know the challenges itself what is
being rendered on to screen before the
technical difficulties we completed the
xi challenge so we'll actually be able
to update that here actually no we won't
update cuz we haven't done a pull
request basically today every 5 that I
do I'm gonna do a pull request and I'll
probably just keep it tally on a note
card just for simplicity sake that way I
can
track of what we're doing so we've done
number 11 which is the first and let's
move right into the next one great okay
so use the spread operator to evaluate a
raise in place introduces spread
operator which allows us to expand
arrays and other expressions in places
where multiple parameters or elements
are expected the es5 code below uses
apply to compute the maximum value in
array returns 89 math dot max that apply
null in the array we had to use null
comm array because math dot max array
returns not a number
now that max expects comma separated
arguments not an array the spread
operator makes this syntax much better
to read and maintain okay it's unpacked
array in other words it spreads it out
yep all right only works in place like
in an argument to a function or in an
array literal the following code does
not work copy all the contents and array
one into another array array two using
the spread operator oh okay
to three array one cool all right so
first thing that comes in mind for a
challenge like this let's see what the
test we have tests that array two is a
correct copy of everyone tests that
array one has changed and then I guess
the part four it's gonna be an issue
though because we can't test before and
after
yes thank you Jesse yeah it's been a we
got everything working now rocking and
rolling alright um test spread operator
was used so I think I think I'm not
gonna do test array one has changed
we're gonna remove that one I definitely
want to test if they're the same I want
to test the spread operator is used and
I think that's all we're gonna have to
do I don't think that this is oh you
don't set it equal to each other I see
well then I'll use a set I'll say that
everything in or a2 is in array one
meaning that it was a copy of it and
then already push who maybe will do
instead I think will do is in the test
itself we'll use something like this and
we'll push an element to it and then
verify afterwards that array two has not
changed so that is will keep this will
keep this challenge simple because what
we're showing here is we're trying to
show that we're just spreading the rheya
in place we're not trying to you know
show on every aspect of like a
assignment and whatnot so this needs to
get updated because there needs to be a
space there okay another thing I noticed
that we don't have the break line so
let's grab that real quick snag that go
over here paste it in now we want to I'm
gonna want to remove this because I
don't think this is important for this
challenge and of course everything that
I'm doing here you know making these
changes and what we'll do is we'll
propose these changes to the repository
and then when someone comes through and
says actually I don't agree with that
then we can go back and we can add them
in but for the purposes of contributing
when you're writing code you get to make
the decisions and then when you
and you make a pull request then that's
when people can challenge you and say I
don't think that's the way to go or you
should do it differently cool
so back to here so let's write some
assert assertion so test that array - is
a correct copy of array 1 all right so
we're in a basic thing and then we're
gonna have some function there comma the
message ok and then we'll just I can
write the message in now array 2 is
correct copy of code array 1 great
remove that for now and get my comma
back over here okay so let's think about
how to do this arrays are a lot of fun
arrays you get to do some fun things
with you get to iterate them you get to
loop through them you get to compare
them get to even use sets so I don't
know what the best way to do this will
be we can probably keep it quite simple
so I'll start by making an arrow
function this way we can contain our
code and then I'll basically can I do
whitespace no I don't believe I can so
to start off we're gonna say constant
array 1 is going to equal just a very
basic array of two elements and then we
want to say that constant array 2 is
going to equal the spread of array 1 and
now we want to compare the two so
traditionally when you want to compare
two arrays I would probably write a DV
equals method to verify that everything
is equivalent but because this is such a
simple example we can actually get away
with doing a return array to zeroth spot
is DP equals the 0th index of array 1
and array 2 is equivalent to array 1
great that should do it for the first
one
now test let's do the let's say this one
for the last cuz we'll talk about that
now let's spread operator was used okay
so we know how the spread operator
should be used and we're going to use a
code match when we get to it all right a
message will say code spread operator
was used now let's go over here we'll
add in our regular expression syntax and
now let's think about the way this
should look so no matter what because we
need array - they need to be producing
array - then we will probably want to
test for this whole line right here with
an optional oh well first of all you
strict and then we have I think this is
valid yes that is so we can have
optional whitespace between here and
here but then we necessary whitespace
here and then also optional whitespace
between here and here it said we don't
even want to test this let's just test
this aspect right here so let's go ahead
and write well I think I have to escape
this yep I have to escape that and
they're gonna have optional whitespace
the spread operator array 1 and then
optional whitespace close the brackets
and we're not gonna test for a semicolon
that's unnecessary and we're gonna say
dot dot dot spread operator was used to
duplicate
array1 make sure we get the clothes in
there believe this is going outside
right yeah cool all right let's let's
work our way back through this to make
sure that everything has worked so far
and then we'll see where we can go just
so I can talk through that basically I
just ran node seed before which reseeds
the database it goes back through all
these JSON files and produces all the
challenges and then I just restarted the
comp the server that is running my
instance of this locally okay so I
believe all I have to do is write dot
dot array one run the tests great they
worked but um before I move on I think I
want to add one more test here I want to
I want to make sure that they aren't
just doing this because if they cuz
technically this is a valid way to copy
an array but that um if I remember
correctly or the way at least this works
in Java is if you were to then edit an
option object like an entity inner a
want it'll actually change it an array
too as well so we want to test to make
sure that what happens in every one
doesn't happen to array - so let's
assert again or actually this may not be
working so I don't have a comma there we
go comma all right assert close that off
let's throw the message in here
now let's say that um will say code
array to remains oh wait okay I just
realized this first test is doing
nothing because it's not I'm just
I just wrote code to check the code we
need to you code match otherwise this is
pointless because this is not like we
can't test what they actually input here
this isn't getting what they've actually
input that's my mistake let me um let's
think about this how can we do this
better we could verify hmm this is a
tricky one
hmm
well technically we really can't check
that Bend because we're not using a
function here what we could do is we
could edit the challenge and see we go
from there so let's say let's make a
function declaration well let's say it's
function or say duplicate and we're
gonna take in an array and we're going
to just return that array what is that
is that reasonable is that a is that a
fair thing to do and then we would want
to say constant array two is going to
equal duplicate array
yeah we're to remove this line would
this still work oh wait no very one yes
it still does okay so let's change the
let's change the challenge here in - so
let's we're gonna change the
instructions here and we're also gonna
change the code so first of all we can
delete this or actually let's keep this
grab that change this line say change
this line and we're basically gonna say
I'm gonna want to complete I'm gonna
want to copy this and I want to do all
my Lum bad line yeah well we'll just
we'll just roll with it all right so we
can delete this one it's already there
and then let's snag this line toss it in
here grab the return
and then grab the squiggly bracket we're
going to need this line here and then
that should be golden okay now you
should be able to say wait a second
we're gonna test one thing real quick
you guys are learning with me here I'm
not entirely sure everything that we
have access to when it comes to this
testing framework I believe this will be
a valid test I think this might work in
which case we don't need all this but
then there is an issue with testing
let's uh we're gonna save this over here
for just a little bit and let's just
snap it into it can I like text at it
I'd like a text edit here we go perfect
let's not let's not have that open
that's my bash profile
alright let's save that in there so we
have that just in case I'll move that
away yes this video will be available
after the live session okay so we've
done that let's go back to writing a
line in that Const array - should just
equal this just edit when they say
change this line
and then this method should return true
if these things are defined okay that's
right a node seed and I'm gonna restart
the server okay let's do a refresh and
let me just go ahead and basically to
remove this uncomment this and then if
this runs okay
this passes this this passes okay so I
was correct I will I was wrong at first
but now I'm correct we do have full
access to the variable types the
variables that are written in the editor
so with that let's think about how we
can check if a raid 2 is equal to array
1 I think a good way to do that is
basically just do basically just use a
for each loop and then I believe before
each we'll pass in the index and yeah
for there so let's just go to mdn and
get the for each method so we can make
sure we do this correctly so it seems
like we get the callback gets the
current value the index in the array
great alright so let's go ahead and
let's go over here I'm gonna say array 2
dot for each and then we're another
callback and the callback is going to
have the current value and the index and
then we're going to know what we'll do
we'll use every instead does I believe
every returns true if it passes for
every op item every and it's a function
let's see so we have the the current
value index as well yep
every guy's gay for awesome he has six
things and then we're going to say we're
gonna return true if V is equivalent to
array one the index if that if this
passes that we know we have a correct
copy we will return false in here for
now remains unchanged or when array one
is changed
I'm gonna restart great let's go back
over here we'll refresh my code should
save good and if we run unlock and run
there we go all right so this one's
passing now which is great that means
that we do have a direct copy of which
is really really good
so this if you guys are wondering this
is the code snippet that I'm using
I'll even post even a copy it and paste
it into the YouTube chat so you guys can
use it in your own thing
so that is a shallow equal array
equivalent see checker what I mean my
shallow equal is that it doesn't truly
check that each item here is equivalent
to the other item because technically if
you had if you guys are aware of some
objects and some nested nested data
structures can lead to being buggy when
you just use a triple check so while
something may actually be the same it
will return false because two objects
even declared exactly the same are not
equal we can even I can even show this
quite quickly in here I believe if we do
this is this gonna be the same yeah so
if you notice two objects of the same
type of literally they literally look
exactly the same but because they're not
the literal same memory address they're
not equivalent so this the method that I
posted there will not work however if
used a deep equals method where it
actually traverses all all keys and
parameters of an item then it would be
better so yeah
let's move right on through here let's
check to make sure that a rate too
remains unchanged so if we go in here we
say array one dot plush and we're gonna
add an item like Jun then
actually now we're going to use a
function I believe so let's pass array
one an array two into there and then
we're going to return that array to dot
length is less than array one dot length
and before I commit I just want to make
sure that that's how you do length yeah
there we go
cool all right save that and run node
seed
restart our server
refresh the page and unlock our code yay
all right good
that's two down let's move right on
through until the next one cool
all right what we got here use the
structuring assignment to assign
variables from objects so earlier we
earlier saw we we saw earlier how spread
operators can effectively spread or
unpack the contents of the array we can
do something similar with objects as
well the structuring assignment is
special syntax for neatly assigning
values taken directly from an object to
variables
consider the following es5 code foxhole
X is 3 point 6 y is 7 point 4 z is 6
point 5 4 ok basic yes 5 here's the same
assignment statement with the SXT
structuring yep if instead you want to
store the values of much logs into a we
you have that freedom as well great ok
use destructuring to obtain the length
of the string reading ok first of all
we're missing the proper wait a second
why is the HR below it spot it's a high
up here that's interesting
we go ahead and snag this anyways we got
to use we have to have that used strict
line I'm still confused why the use
divides the things underneath it well
we'll roll with it okay so we want to
say use destructuring to obtain the
length of the string greeting Oh
interesting
oh okay so let's think about this if we
have a string in node we're actually
solving the challenges two guys is kind
of fun so let's say we have our string
you know we'll just say like ABC you
want to get the length you just type
that length right so if you think about
it this dot length there's a property of
the object ABC or the string so what you
should be able to do in that instance is
go ahead and say Const or we'll just use
I'll just use let length equals let's
just do length we'll assign it to the
word it's the letter L equals
ABCDEF l should be six perfect all right
so that what we're expecting here is
curly brackets around the word length
and it should equal greeting this is the
expected solution and we want to test
that destructuring was used I also want
to make this challenge a little bit more
and I want to assign it to Len I want I
want the user to assign the length to
the word le n um because the word but
the string length is technically a key
word because it's so popular of
parameter for arrays as well as strings
so let's go ahead and go into our code
first well let's add some white line
space in here
great so I want to say use destructuring
to obtain the length of the string
reading comma and assign that assign the
length to code Len great this is gonna
be a fun one assert and then length this
is really equal just equals 11 was
remember they got to use the Elian
otherwise it won't work
and then message is going to be code
only n
equals 11 cool then we can say sir we're
gonna want to make sure that the length
was assigned to line so we should what
we should test that length exist so
we'll start with that assert type of Len
equals equals equals string string and
then the message is code constant we're
going to say variable length exists and
is a string that's that
okay and if we want to make sure that's
how that actually comes out we'll just
do yep string now let's assert that our
users actually went ahead and used
destructuring so properly D structured
or just was gonna say destruction was
used I think that's I don't think
there's a better way to say that okay
so let's do code match close it off get
our rejects ready let's think about how
this is gonna look so we're definitely
we don't need to worry about cons but we
definitely need the squiggly bracket and
then we gonna have the optional
whitespace we need the strict word
length there's another way to get it and
then we need the optional whitespace the
colon optional whitespace the strict
word @ en optional whitespace close the
bracket off and then we should just test
for pretty much that whole line so we
can do optional whitespace equal sign
optional whitespace greeting because
they really shouldn't there really
shouldn't be any deviation from this and
we'll skip the semicolon because people
don't always put them so let's go ahead
and write that it's ready all right
regular expressions go so I believe I'm
gonna to get rid of the Sui Lee mark and
then optional whitespace the word length
optional whitespace : an optional
whitespace weird le an optional
whitespace pletely bracket optional
whitespace equal sign
optional whitespace the word greeting
alright great
let's roll with that
first need here node seed
anyone has any any questions feel free
to reach out in the chat I'd love to
answer them change that out
of something broke
ah something failed here Oh on inside
token all right where did we go wrong I
see I see okay
no trailing comma it's JSON for you
Stephen please ask any questions man I'd
love that I'd love to help out all right
we're running again
let's refresh all right so code did not
save so let's go ahead and let's type in
the potential solution
and the tests oh all right
so what went wrong here
she doesn't need to be a string that is
completely wrong I don't know why my
brain was thinking that it needs to be a
number I was thinking Lane but like
string I don't know let's just roll with
that so that one's good on let's be
verbose here and actually check to make
sure that edit makes sense
our Codel it's luckily this local uses
local storage and will store my code so
all I have to do is refresh and run the
tests again and we should be set to move
on to the next one that would bring us
up to three awesome refresh okay
scroll down unlock the code run the test
and happy coding all right
three four three guys let's go to the
next one use the structuring assignment
to assign variables from nested objects
we can similarly do structure nested
objects into variables consider
following code a start Oh what wait what
so we're saying get the variable start
the property start from a and then from
the object and then then get X but I'm
sorry store that as the object oh this
is a confusing one I'd actually never
used this yes I can fill you in what
we're doing so we are contributing to
free code camp right now we are writing
on tests for the es6 challenges at the
same time we're doing a little bit of QA
we are I'm going through the beta
challenges and I am not only am i
reading through the descriptions and
trying to test out the challenges just
as is and filling out some of the
solutions but I'm also writing the tests
that tests to make sure that everyone
else is solutions in the future will
pass as well and while I'm doing that
I'm explaining a couple years six things
and if I'm open to question
and soon once we hit five five
challenges for two-way I will be doing
some github stuff to show you all like
what it's like to push and pull from the
github the free code camp repository
great so the maximum of tomorrow so this
is gonna be a complicated one I think
first of all we know that we're gonna be
assigning this to the word forecast and
Max of tomorrow he's going so we got to
start with today and then we gotta say
max assign that to the word max of
tomorrow and that nested block should do
it I don't exactly have a way to test it
but I'm just gonna run the test it's
gonna pass but we didn't actually write
anything that just saved my code so now
let's write some tests we're also
missing the use strict line I don't know
if the use strict line needs to exist
I'm gonna keep copying and pasting it
over until and I think it'll just be a
very easy cleanup job if we don't
actually need it
excited rather put it in there and then
remove it later on
so this one's an easy one this Alliance
we're just gonna write a cert max of
tomorrow equals equals equals a 4.6 and
then the message is going to be simple
as this
that and now talk about we're gonna say
nested restructuring was used so I'm
going to test for this line pretty much
exactly there there's really is no other
way to do it um and with that let's do
whenever if you guys are wondering I am
writing some stuff down on the notebook
just so I can see it um keep in mind and
also shout out to github got a little
Hugh bot github notebook pretty special
definitely guys should get some yes even
these are this challenges that you see
when you work through free code camp
we're writing them right now
so that when we release the beta
hopefully on Christmas we'll have some
fun things for you all to see
all right let's go through here we're
gonna have the screwy bracket potential
whitespace weird today
optional whitespace colon optional white
space squiggly optional whitespace the
word max optional white space :
optional white space max of tomorrow
optional white space 20 bracket optional
white space squiggly optional white
space equals optional white space
forecast great this is gonna be a nice
and long we eat regular expressions
let's go ahead and write this um first
of all yeah well let's just roll through
here we're gonna say assert code dot
match message
I get that in there hello how you all
doing today see someone just is here
from India
it's pretty awesome I'm in the US and
I'm in New Jersey at the moment even
though I spend a lot of time in Boston
let's go all right guys ready for this
regular expression escape the squiggly
optional whitespace the word today
optional white space :
optional white space open squiggly
bracket and then optional white space
the word max optional white space :
optional white space max of to morrow
optional white space close the solutely
bracket close the next weekly racket but
there also needs to be some optional
white space in between more optional
white space the equal sign more optional
white space the word forecast great is
there anything else you want to test I
think that's a solid one
all right let's let's let me just check
over max of tomorrow's equivalent good
and then we have we have the eat the Oh
close or sorry open optional today
optional : optional open optional max
optional : optional the word max of
tomorrow optional closed optional closed
optional equals optional forecast
will attest for single white space or
all white space between levers what
between letters great question so the
reason why I'm using this right here is
an optional it's wild card which means
it can be zero or many I can show you
that in here so let's simplify this
let's just literally do we're gonna say
a optional white space B and we're gonna
say that a and we have ton of white
space back passes we have a B here and
we can do a single space and all three
of these pass these are all valid for
this regular expression so what we're
doing is we're basically saying there
can be white space there can also be no
white space and that's okay and that's
what this is testing for in fact the /s
is white space and then the wild card
means zero or many we also have a plus
sign for one or many and then I think
there's one more I believe it's zero or
none so there's the IE is that what this
is it's zero and one so if you have one
if you so for example this does not pass
but these two do so those are our three
white space tests great alright that ran
let's run
oh yeah let's run ode seed and then
let's go here and restart the server
what time is it it is almost 3:00 p.m.
for me in the afternoon which would be
1500 if you're on military time like I
usually a.m.
alright let's refresh this saved it
unlock the code run it alright something
to not work why does it not equal that
who can tell me oh because I made a
mistake in my solution see that guy's to
morrow you'd think that I would catch
that but you get kind of caught off
thinking about the code and which means
that I did this incorrect this needs to
be the word tomorrow instead
all right let's be verbose check it and
get on to the next one that work Oh No
okay broke go
cool all right let's see well I
apologize for the dog barking all right
unlock the code run it and we're off to
the next one all right guys that is for
let's do one more and then we'll do a
little commit some things to get and do
some fun things all right yes six makes
destructuring arrays as easy as
destructuring objects it does one key
difference between the spread operator
an array destructuring is that the
spread operator unpacks all contents of
an array into a comma-separated list
consequently you cannot pick or choose
which elements you want to assign to
variables ah oh I know what this is
doing let's do this the variable
variable a is assigned to the first
value of the array and B is assigned the
second value of the array we can also
access the value at any index in the
write with the structure means and
commas to reach a desired index use the
structuring assignment to swap the
values of a and of a and B so that a
receives the value stored in B and B
receives the value stored in a I think
it wants us to do
yes
Oh looks like this one might already
have tests let's see look at that
well it would seem you're right
alright guys let's see what they have
here I see they're testing for a word
why would it be testing for two comma
one it doesn't make a lot of sense Oh
unless they're using they're pulling
let's just run it and see what happens
okay so let me um not I guess it right
works so we're gonna skip this one
because if it's running it works but I'm
not entirely sure I guess what this is
doing I don't I'm not familiar regular
expressions enough to say but I guess
this is actually grabbing oh the zoo
capturing groups that's what it is okay
so guys um let's learn let's do some
learn something fun here so if you
notice this here and you see where it
also copied secondly these are capturing
groups you notice that by the
parentheses around the word folk /w that
matches any character any any like
character a through Z upper case lower
case as well as 0 to 9 and underscores I
believe so that captures the character
and in this one this is this is gonna
capture and store it as like capture one
and then this second capturing group
with the second set of parentheses says
grab the next letter and say store it in
capture two then later on in his regular
expression his or her regular expression
this you escaped a number and that will
refer to a previous capturing group so
this too refers to this capturing group
right here while this one refers to this
caption group right here awesome
alright let's submit and go to the next
so that was technically that was 11
through 15 I believe let's just check so
use what's what was the title the last
one to assign variables from array yep
so we just did 11 through 15 so let's
take a quick break from coding we're
actually going to push some stuff to get
first off let's go ahead and cancel this
and turn these off and then let's think
about the right way to do this I want to
actually get my PO request up as well
there may be a communication here all
right haven't gotten any review yet so
where so this is a pull request that I
have which is currently tracking the
future requests my IDs six tests so
because of the beginning of this video
back when we were doing technically
we're working through technical
difficulties I am merged I I mean I
updated my branch to the master so we're
gonna happen that we currently have no
merge issues with this with this PR so
we're gonna be safe to plush to it and
with that let's run git status and see
what was changed so notice the only
thing that's changed the JSON file
that's a good thing because that's the
only thing we've been typing in the
whole day and what's awesome about free
code camp is that it actually has a NPM
run commit command and what this will
let us do is create our commits but
something is not working
ah get add now run npm run commit great
so we'll go down to the word test and
well then we're gonna say challenges and
then we're gonna do a sort sort short
message we're just gonna say on yes six
chow 11 through 15 it might not be
working because of the numbers
no issue numbers so it's gonna it
doesn't like me putting things we're
gonna say like see eleven through see
fifteen will that work there we go we
don't really need to any of these
awesome I have an MDM update I'll go run
that real quick while we go check out oh
well here hold on a sec guys alright run
that and now let's check on here so
we're refresh and yes it should any
second now this should pop up with our
commit right no we have to get push here
we go
push our commit origin feature add yes
six Tests here we go okay so we had to
commit you've pushed the commit and now
if you look over here we'll give it a
minute
ah boom right there it pops up it's
running camber BOTS running Travis CI is
running to make sure that the build
builds successfully and from here we
would be good to merge now I do have the
ability to merge into master however I
do not enjoy I want I always want
someone to look over my code before I do
that
so until then we're just gonna keep
pushing here and as long as we maintain
the forget the word I guess they'll the
correctness of our branch which is
feature IDs six tests then we'll be fine
the way we do that is when I ran through
before where I fetched the upstream
master or the upstream staging reset my
branch to that and then cherry picked my
commits so what I'm gonna to keep doing
is until I get to that point I'm just
gonna keep cherry-picking these three
commits until we're good to go alright
so we're done with those five are there
any questions in the chat before I move
on to the next five
you guys have an amazing bootstrap
walkthrough any plans of making sass or
CSS grid material well let's see what we
have over here responsive web design we
have the basic CSS visual design
accessibility web design principles we
have the flex box tutorial an applied
design so in front-end libraries we have
bootstrap and we also have sass right
here
I believe yet it hasn't even has
challenges Stephen so um you definitely
it's coming it's in beta and yeah cool
let's also go ahead and update here we
know that we polar crust finished so
we're gonna go ahead and update our
emojis so that if someone else wants to
come by and check that you'll be like oh
yeah look what all the work they've done
cool halfway there guys halfway there
let us get right back into coding before
I do that I'm gonna take a quick drink
of water and make sure this was run yeah
we're good here we'll get everything
going again hey drink always stay
hydrated everybody it's important thing
to do
poor brain food called gummy bears
all right and we're on to the next one
destructuring assignment with the rest
operator to reassign array elements I
use this one a lot okay
a B D structure the rest of the array
great
the rest element only works correctly as
the last variable in the list as in you
cannot use the rest operator to catch a
sub ray that we use outlast Allen
originally cool
Stephen are you working through the beta
or are you working through the main
curriculum alright so the challenge is
we're basically just going to do a slice
and we just want to take the first two
out main curriculum all right cool
yeah keep keep going through the main
curriculum Steven and you'll see there's
a little bit of sass in the data visual
section but I don't know it's not going
to be if I remember correctly it's not
gonna be as you are familiar with like
with all the testing and stuff I believe
in the new curriculum that actually is
tested and all that fun stuff okay so
how would this look I think this is as
simple as going we would just be
structure typing backwards see everybody
do a be cool
that should work and there doesn't seem
to be any test so let's go ahead and
write some tests all right so we have to
do a deep equals again our shallow
equals I had the code snippet so we
already know we can do that again
we'll just plop that into a text thing
just so I have it
that's assert then put the message in
here
we're gonna say code array is code
No um oh here's a fun one ready so just
do well just say array dot every and
then we're going to literally do the I
is value is equivalent to I plus two so
we're doing a little you know a little
like Chi D thing here we're basically
just notice that or actually index would
be plus three because like you know you
have 0 1 0 plus 3 is 3 1 plus 3 is 4 so
on and so forth what's a good one that's
that's an easy way to do this because
we're just using the incrementals and
then we can the new assert a source dot
every comma i say that the value is
equivalent to i plus 1 instead and say
our message is code source code is i'll
copy that in a second and we got to
finish the message block comma
great let's get rid of these okay so we
have two easiest certs to write so let's
start with the first one and we'll say
assert that the code matches regular
expression and we put the message in
here and we're going to keep working
through so destruction was used let's go
back and look at our code so we know our
solution basically is going to have some
word character Sammy I have been coding
for about four years now but I've really
only been doing the open source thing
since like really like heavily like this
past September but I've been familiar
with the get kind of ass back for about
a year I'm sorry an optional whitespace
word character optional weight or word
character optional whitespace comma
optional whitespace so much fun
whitespace word character optional
whitespace comma optional whitespace
destructuring with the word array
because we needed to be named array
optional whitespace closed bracket
that'll be good enough regular
expression I believe so we have to do
the open go here then do the optional
word character it needs to be one so
we'll just do strictly one yep just
leave it as is optional word character
comma optional word character optional
space word character optional space
open a missing link comma optional space
dot dot array optional space and close
bracket all right and we got one more
assert at the code dot match so we want
to know that slice was not used so a fun
one to write is you literally just you
look for the word slice but you just
know you just flip it to make sure that
they didn't actually put it in there or
say array dot slice was not used and
I'll probably write this I'll do array
dot because this is literal might have
to do this
that's a BAM or something like that
Steven I'm not sure what you mean by
baam BAM
Sammy says planning to study electrical
and electronic engineering next year
which programming takes a big chunk out
of the course but sometimes I don't know
where to start and feel overwhelmed
Sammy one thing I can tell you is coding
is a wild roller coaster and there's a
really awesome community especially here
at free code camp for you to learn so if
you just start out as small as you
possibly can and just keep working your
way up eventually it'll be you know
second nature and with electrical and
electronic engineering what I've been
told is that you really you're kind of
programming will be more lower level
instead of like you know a lot of a high
level object-oriented stuff especially
not even like web design you won't
really see um unless you decide to take
that of course and with lower level with
lower level programming it will be more
complicated but if you get a good sense
of math some discrete structures you
know learn the basic syntax of
JavaScript and Python which we will be
working heavily on you should be really
sure you should be set and just take it
slow take your time learning these
things it doesn't it's not gonna come
overnight but it's definitely doable and
there's also a lot of fun support so we
you can always reach out if you need it
let me write this message and I'll
respond which one was this oh yeah the
structure D structuring was used all
right I think I got another question
here while I write
I'll do the node seed while I read this
how are you feeling about the view Jas
framework I just started learning it
need to know you need to know do you
think if it will get picked up because
as of now there isn't much Doc's about
it
so UJS is a incredible framework I do
not know it yet I do plan on learning it
it's a great thing to have in your tool
kit there is for what I understand there
is a pretty decent Docs and actually has
a lot of really cool um add-ons as well
I believe there's something called like
nuts is which is um a view j/s like
like almost like static web loader I
believe really good for front-end
projects view is a lot smaller than
react and it thinks a lot
computationally less doesn't have the
same obviously it's not going to be the
same as react it's a great thing to have
in your tool belt and I wouldn't
discount it I just think that react has
a react does have a very large presence
in the front end thing but they're not
the only one and definitely learn view
if you can what motivated me to get into
programming started with for me was just
I always thought coding was this really
cool thing you know though you know you
always see it on like TV and stuff like
hackers and things and I was like well I
can't become a hacker so uh let me learn
how to build websites so I did I learned
used to I think code Academy when it
used to be like completely free and I
learned that in high school and then
from there I just kept working on it and
eventually worked my way up until doing
JavaScript and then getting more
complicated from there earning some
looking into object-oriented programming
and basically running with it
alright we got everything that passed
except one guys let's figure out what
happened know something did not work was
that a there's something wrong with me
here no all right
why did source not work
hmm 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 good views guys
I don't know what's wrong with this line
let me um we run it a node real quick oh
I'm missing something
nope well I'm not even a node oh wait
interesting
you know what's doing this why would
that run false source that every is not
a function Stephen says how long did it
take you to learn node still learning
node actually then a little bit of
contributing I've gone to two node
conferences and that has helped a lot
sort of use as much small I need to pick
up angular and react to my goals dead
zombie I'd encourage you to focus on one
of them and then when you are very
confident with one of them then pick up
another and then leave it at that I
think learning all three might be a
little overkill and you'll realize that
there really isn't a point especially
the difference between angular and the
act I would encourage you to go with
react it's much more widely adopted and
a lot more like some popular open source
projects like free code camp I find it a
little bit easier to understand and like
I said do react then view or the other
way around do view then react that's my
personal opinion but I would refrain
from going through all three it might be
a little overkill
um alright guys let's see what is
happening the source being edited is
that why does I don't think that that
would affect it but what is source okay
hey B and then array guys I don't
understand what's going on
let's um go back we run nodes seed one
more time I will say node oh you know
what it might be I think it has to do
with the STD out let's see maybe that's
it unlock the code room the console says
source is not defined I don't know well
hi
I see the console says
source that every is not a function but
I Rea had every is a function oh gosh
this is really confusing guys I don't
know what's wrong
well then I'll just get rid of this line
I don't know what's up and it doesn't
make sense I think it might have to do
with how we're spitting things out of
these tests because obviously it's not
just running so there might have to do
is the way like what is being passed
through exactly sure okay we'll get rid
of that and the other ones are passing
so we're gonna one more time run node
seed and that is our took once a while
but that was our first challenge for
this set
do a little restart let's keep pushing
through Google refresh
you know I don't even know why we'd have
to test source to begin with the thought
being it's not being written by the user
great all right guys we're on to the
next one
destructuring assignments to pass an
object as a functions parameters in some
cases you can D structure the object in
a function argument itself consider that
yep okay yeah it does all right let's
see what this wants to do use function
argument destructuring I think I know
exactly what it wants basically just
write max min
yeah
it will run our test just so we have our
code saved now let's get to writing them
something I'm not
yeah that's just go go being gold yeah
Stephen is very right on you just if you
just you know one it's really easy to
learn another and if you know something
in coding like if you learn Python it
for exactly fever in JavaScript do a
well you can take that directly over to
Python and then when you know Python
really well you'll be and you have that
object-oriented mindset you'll be able
to pick up Java or C++ or C sharp and
you'll be you'll be perfect if you don't
mind me asking how old are you I do not
mind I am nineteen years old
cool alright let's test these things
assert stances and objects sure we can
do that type of stats equals equals
equals object
yeah gogo 19 cool all right and on to
the next it's an easy one let's do
another another easy one here assert
that the value half is equivalent to
twenty eight point zero one five
yeah sorry half is
have I had any coding internships jobs I
do I have I started off as a web
developer in high school part-time and
then from there I did a lot of there's a
little bit of freelance not a lot just a
little bit of freelance and then I went
to college or university and learned a
bunch of new programming stuff join some
clubs went to some events like a
hackathon and then from there I built
some my own stuff and then did some open
source and then recently I accepted a
position as an intern with Microsoft for
next summer so going up cool all right
let's check destructuring was used we
need to test for this line right here so
let's do some write downs right we got
parentheses empty whites optional white
squiggly optional the word max or
technically not the word max we can just
do we'll just do word that max that
matches a single character though right
there we go cool I will do another one
like that
with the optional white spaces in
between and another optional white space
close it off white space parentheses
thank you very much Sammy I wish you the
best of luck with your with your
endeavors - all right let's keep going
through so open that up or escape it
optional that optional word optional
optional word optional escape it
optional close it say D structuring was
used all right have a go on man
thanks for joining us okay save that and
let's do go here a node seed
now we will restart
refresh unlock the code run it half is
not 20 8.05 well maybe that's not the
right math so let's see fifty six point
seven eight plus it was like oh wow I
don't even remember I can't remember it
alright let me just go ahead and do it a
node 56.7 eight plus negative 0.75
divided by two
oh I don't have these let's go over here
okay that should be that but it's not so
let's find out why
what is half let's check our console
half is twenty-eight point one five so I
don't know why this is failing
well half is a I see ready
so half itself is a function not just a
variable so we actually have to pass it
the variable stats and then we have to
say half stats is it all right there we
go you start the server
refresh the page unlock it and run it
we're golden
alright we're flying through these
mountain on to number 18 a new feature
of es6 is template literals your I gotta
love template literals use temperate
little syntax with backticks to display
each entry of the results object of the
result objects failure array each entry
should be wrapped inside a list element
with the class attribute text warning
whoa what is this asking
all right if we're gonna help this
challenge out here it's a little
confusing but we're first of all I'm
gonna call this result display array so
people get an idea that they're actually
dealing with it right here each entry
are the result objects failure right
each entry should be wrapped inside a
list element with the class attribute
tax code warning comma and listed within
the what's the variable name result
display array great
okay
so I'm going to do result dot failure
dot map I'm just gonna pass the string
into a anonymous arrow function and this
is just going Li ya map map does it
right yeah actually we're gonna have
some fun here I'm just gonna get rid of
that and I'm just gonna one line in it
yay for one lining okay so start off
it's gonna have a li class equals text
warning and then template literal V and
then close out the Li all right run it
yeah we passed didn't do anything
actually Wow alright um it looks like
this is a very literal challenge so it
seems like we can kind of be stricter
with our tests result display as a
string
now that's two I'm not gonna put now
we're gonna we're gonna do this way I
like the way that I did it making
executive decisions when you're right on
the code you get to make the decisions
we're gonna say that results display
array first of all type of is I believe
it's array
oh it's object like that well it's
better than it being like a string so is
a list containing code results
and we'll do a little fun result failure
messages
we'll say and result display array dot
length is three that's a good enough one
say our message is here we'll just grab
this
okay get rid of that and then we have to
test for desired output okay
there used to be a way to provide a
there there there was there may probably
still is I just don't know it so I don't
want to deal with it right now but I
know there's a way you can provide a
solution that you can test there's
against but I think for the instance is
this I'm just gonna do here ready that
every value it's going to equal value
needs to equal and then we're just gonna
use where if you use the exact same
thing but
and instead of putting V here we're
gonna do what is it called result dot
failure I
result display array is the desired
output
test template strings were used all
right how do we do that
you ask well simply put we're gonna need
right now we're gonna have to use the
code dot match and then the message okay
they need to use template literals along
with the blink stuff but I don't want to
like limit them this is a tricky one
because there's many ways to do it and
some valid ways and I don't want to
discourage
can't be too strict but also can't be
too last so what if I can definitely at
least test for what if we did like we
want to test the code for the back tech
then potentially y'all man hmm that's
the line that we want them to use is
there any other way to do it they could
concatenate but that's against the rule
we're against the rules so I think we
should just test for this literally
coding in caffeine I could use some
caffeine god I'd be a great it'd be a
great thing to have right about now
maybe maybe if we if we go for maybe
when we reach the next five I'll go make
a cup of coffee during a little break
all right let's copy that and let's just
flop it in right here this is gonna be
tricky one cuz I don't know if I have to
escape everything in here I think I've
got to escape those let's just run this
through real quick over here
we got to put one here too
escaped it and then we also need to
escape the back tech that's important
okay
and then if this in this instance we
would have then that's not much hold on
so I can pass those in it there we go
cool
okay so snag you put you in there and we
gotta just go back through and double
tick a bunch of these those don't need
to get double ticked yeah a big huge cup
of coffee yeah sound sounds about right
I mean yeah you can't do that cuz that's
that's for the test all right guys
template strings where she used where is
that
alright let's go for it
haven't tested this one yet
great work let's run the test once to
swim make sure it's saved and now
refresh unlock the code run the test fry
everything runs things broke result
display array not defined everything
broke now result displays not defined oh
excuse me there we go guys
all right that's number three two more
and I get a cup of coffee let's do it
alright he is six add some nice support
for easily to finding object literals
what our object literals oh oh oh I know
what this is all it's asking us to do is
just use this Oh God commas in so
basically we're gonna test for I know
what I'm gonna do well let's see what
they say test that the output is named
zodiac Hasbro 56 male test no colon is
present yeah so we'll test will foo we
also it's an object so attendant we
can't I shouldn't test our order of
things cool let's do this
let's first run the task so our code
gets saved and then we'll go through
here and write some tests
all right assert that the outputs of
create person oh we need D people's oh
let's see how a good learn J s book I
don't what's books you can read um learn
es6 the hard way I think that one's free
online has some good stuff in there
eloquent JavaScript is also a good one
has some as I don't know how updated
it's been it's been a few years since
they released I will quit I'm not sure
if it's been fully updated especially
not the es6 maybe it has can't remember
also yeah mdn is a really good one I'm I
mean I actually have it open right now
it's it's just my it's my go-to I find
their documentation very nice I never
read the w3 schools documentation
anymore it's I'm strictly going at the
end even for HTML and CSS and then
Steven asked how did I learn JavaScript
this has been the biggest roadblock for
me I feel like I learned relearn and get
nowhere
ah this is a great question um first of
all it's like practice makes perfect
just I started off with code Academy I
think the amount of JavaScript tutorials
I've done probably is like way too many
I think I've done one on the code
Academy I've done the free code camp
curriculum I've done the w3 schools
thing if you've added curriculum I've
done udemy
I've tried like Coursera as well as I
think even treehouse by for very brief
time so I've had a lot of different
resources
I find udemy worked for me so when you
fought first when you find the resource
that works for you keep going back to
that resource Udacity that's another
good one
there's a little bit more expensive
sometimes and recently egghead io they
have a good they have a good curriculum
stuff but again they have a little bit
of a price tag so you figure out your
Learning Resource you go through the
videos and then then there's an aspect
of putting it to use
you really nothing will really stick if
you don't use it and that said you don't
need to use it all the time but you need
to apply it so I think the difference of
the use and apply is sometimes people
miss you need to apply what you learn
and you can do that through many ways
you can start side projects you can
update projects you built while learning
you can also contribute to open source
now I tend to do the two of them I
contribute to open source as you can see
and I also write my own projects I
believe I have I have to actively
develop projects active actively
developing projects right now both in
JavaScript both is with react and both
of them are quite different but use a
lot of the same features so I'm doing a
lot of new things for each of them
for example one of them is gonna have a
very awesome authentication API using
off zero
which I've never gotten to play with
before so I'm learning by applying my
JavaScript skills to that and the other
one is strictly just a lot of database
stuff so I'm working with a lot of data
yes they both are I think I can actually
believe one of them if you guys just
bear with me a second I'll get up I'll
show you guys my github and I'll put the
links in the chat so you can see the
projects that I'm talking about one of
them is cookie jar it doesn't have any
code just yet and the other one is
Viking honors manager so here's one of
them I believe it's not on master yet
I'm still working on integrate on an
integrate method on a branch to
integrate a database into it so that one
the master branch on that one is
outdated but then I also have this new
project which I'm doing a lot more
planning on but has if you look in it
there should be some pngs
those have
mock-ups for stuff that I plan on adding
so yeah those are the two projects that
I'm currently working on both
open-source but probably not as nicely
open-source as some other projects are
alright back to the coding you're
looking at this before yes we got to
assert that create person well we should
probably just copy this Oh what are the
objects the object quality I think the
object has a gadot equals method but I'm
not sure Oh are they private repos oh
let me see
sorry about that I think yeah I'll make
I can make cookie jar public cookie jar
is public I believe
yeah cookie jars public but the what the
Viking honors is not so the what's are
called the Viking honors one is not and
that I think I need to keep it that way
because it's going to be for um
something the summer summer camp that I
work for yeah maybe I don't know how to
tell if it's fine or not
nope it doesn't seem like it's private
uh-huh I get a 404 for which one maybe
it's maybe it has to do with the way
YouTube does links but if you guys look
me up on github
I have a ton of repositories and then
one repo is called Viking honours
manager and then another one is cookie
jar so oh that's been correct that the
other one is called bat so those are the
two project names on github if you
wanted to lock them up cool we were
looking for object equals but it doesn't
really do that it has something else
yeah keys
okay yeah YouTube I don't think you I
don't think YouTube supports links and
um its chat or if it does it's weird
about it
let me see real quick okay cool let's
keep moving forward so we're gonna do
some real funky JavaScript so first
we're going to wrap our result object in
object keys and we're gonna say dot
for oh this is a hard one
I think I can do Const name equals
Zodiac Hasbro constant age equals 56 and
then constant gender equals oh wait this
shouldn't be a string gender equals male
then our function well now that it's not
a function now it will do return object
uh keys that create person name age
gender dot every value
oh well this is now this is every key
every key needs to be the value wait I
think it might be better fitted Const
results
bear with me guys we're getting there
there might be a better way to do this
so if anyone noticed if anyone knows
make sure to make sure to say so I'll
keep tabs on the comment section of this
video too after the fact so if you guys
are watching this in the future
definitely give me some input I'd love
to hear it and I'll definitely you know
everything can get changed so let me
know and you can also review it and
github let me know if there's things
that you want changed alright so that's
the result that's what we want and then
we're gonna go ahead and copy those
three things again place it into here
and then we're gonna say the every key
and we want the the result to be and
sorry guys
yeah we're an I how about this the new
constant P person equals
and then we need to return object that
keys person got every key I'm just a
person key is going to be equivalent to
result key all right okay I think that
does that Wow and what's what's the
intended message the output is
okay great and now let's do it no we
have to get to finish up with an easy
one
no colons exist anywhere in this one
no we're used all right guys
wow that was this was a harder one could
also be the caffeine that I need
weird Bruce Moriarty oh cool the link
works your name is also very familiar I
believe there's a character in the
Sherlock Holmes show I was watching that
today and I think he has your name now
expected expression got keyword Const
all right we need to wrap this in a
function B yeah it does have your
surname I knew it
don't ruin it for me I haven't finished
watching the episode yet let's see
that's that and let's read Oh No always
break gold can't just one-up it you got
a very tight butt every time all right
here we go
fresh fresh going try again here we go
there we go
lock it run it then it passes
Carlos can you use gold watch yes
so gulp is watching but even if it was
watching the json files we're it's how
to explain this
we need to rerun gulp when the database
gets updated not when the json file gets
updated so when we the reason why i'm
doing update the json gold probably
already refreshes i wouldn't be
surprised if it's not but at that point
the database hasn't been changed so it
doesn't matter so when we run node seed
a tree does it like re-entries things in
the database and then you refresh gulp
and it re queries things and then it
pumps it all back into the page this is
just the development it's a way the
development works it's kind of it's not
optimal and hopefully it'll change in
the future but that's just how things
are going at the moment
give me one hot second also we just
finished another challenge so ok look at
us nothing can stop us now
all right great
that is for all right we're on to the
next one one more and then I get to get
coffee and then I'll do probably five
more and be done for the evening
afternoon when defining functions within
objects and es5 if you use a keyword
function as follows
he has six you can remove the function
keyword and : all together when defining
functions and objects here's an example
of the syntax we factor the function set
gear inside the object bicycle all right
so I think all we have to do is write
like here
okay hold on a second what is this I
test the output is sending request to
you no shimamoto who is that is that
that's not the Bitcoin guy is it because
the no that's something with an ass
right who created created Bitcoin
yeah that's Satoshi Nakamoto yeah no she
min moto well no idea but let's keep
coding
I guess I guess he was the guy that I
created this challenge in the first
place all right Oh God let's do it
all right well it sounds like this guy
doesn't actually know what he wants me
to test but we'll do it anyways
basically we want to verify that sexier
still works so let's do a
before-and-after test
so we're gonna say calm or we'll say
actually we know that - we just do by
sickle dot gear equals equals equals 2
and and by sick call dot set gear
all we can do I'll just do this don't
get too complicated we'll just set it
equal to like 48 and then we'll say oh
this do you will use a function and it
will say return bicycle dot gear equals
48 yeah that's good message
could set gear is a function and changes
the gear very open code gear variable
great and we already wrote this one
so let's just snag that
all right I'm sure noted seed give it a
few seconds and we're gonna restart gulp
refresh the page
see the issue is this won't work because
gear is using it so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna check that set gear
doesn't have it with it
so traditionally set gear would have
looked like set gear right what's the
original and then it would have to have
the function so we're actually gonna
test for this little bit right there
okay I know I know we're doing what's
this thing called
we call this declarative function was
used and we're gonna say code dot match
well we'll start with the callin and
then we'll have the optional whitespace
the word function and then open closed
with a optional white space in there
we'll make sure that that doesn't exist
okay
yes victory is ours another five
completed let's commit the work and then
I'm gonna take a very short break to get
some coffee and then get right back to
it so before I leave
let's first shut down gulp then shut
down run get status at our
challenge npm run commit we're gonna say
test challenges es6 challenges would we
do we did 16 C 16 probably through C 20
at this point which one is this use
class syntax to define a constructor
function use class syntax it that's 21
so we did see 16 through C 20 nothing
else necessary and then get push origin
feature add es6 tests alright and that
does it for those just go back over here
give it a minute it should pop up and
then we'll see what's to do next
No is it gonna refresh for me usually it
does that automatically there we go
well some go through here guys look at
all these cut great we're doing awesome
alright and this probably just pass oh
now it's running running through there
how many more do we have we only have
seven more I mean we probably could
finish it all right well I want five
minutes and then I will be back to push
through these last seven and then
that'll be all the tests are in for the
s6 challenges so yeah
be back in five let me just type that in
here can I say something
yes I can't here we go be back in five
minutes
I got coffee and now I'm back it's time
to do some awesome coding and finish up
these challenges all right you've got a
couple questions hey how can I become a
contribute camp yeah so Quincy sent out
a message on medium I'm Carlos
definitely right there's also a
contributor channel on git earth
normally I have out on this browser but
there's one on there so you can totally
use that and I don't think there's
really much else to it a lot of stuff
I'm doing today is what like we need
when it comes to contributing so if you
have this kind of JavaScript skill then
like let us know we'll get you set up
and it's a lot of fun too so far today
we've worked through basically eleven
through twenty we've done these ten
challenges we've done a little bit of QA
with them try to like test out what
they're actually asking and then we need
some edits and things and write some
tests and soon I'm gonna jump right back
into it with the next seven and then
hopefully when we finish these seven
I'll be able to merge everything into
the actual repo and we can get some
people running through them and getting
some feedback and I'll be able to make
more changes later on there's also a
user in here earlier who's literally
named like coffee and Kathy or code and
caffeine or something and it was like
yeah could use some of that okay let's
get back into it so we'll move this up
here
you okay we see we got used class syntax
define a constructor function and you've
getters and setters to control access to
an object understand the differences
between import and require I actually
don't know the differences between those
two I'm still confused about it so I'll
be a fun one to learn use export to
reuse the code block cool use and
percent or you start to import
everything from a file you start to
import everything from a file import a
default export I think I got a duplicate
in there so well we'll get through that
but alright we are back to it it's run
be debatable then we'll gulp
and go back to the bash now let's get
back to coding es6 provides a new syntax
to help create objects using the keyword
class this is to be noted that the class
syntax is just a syntax and not a
full-fledged class-based implementation
of object-oriented paradigm
unlike in languages like Java Python
Ruby in es5 we usually define a
constructor function and use the new
keyword to instantiate an object the
class syntax simply replaces the
constructor function creation yes it
does
notice that the class keyword declares a
new function and a constructor was added
which would be invoked when new is
called to create a new object use class
keyword and write a proper constructor
to create the vegetable class the
vegetable lets you create a vegetable
object with a property name to be passed
to the constructor sweet sounds good to
me
all right class vegetable
and a little styling going kind struktur
we'll just call it name this dot name
equals name oh can you guys hear the
fans
yeah they kickin in aren't they yeah I'm
actually working off a MacBook this is
just a standard MacBook Pro I believe so
things doing a quite a lot you know
coding is live streaming off and coding
at the same time I think it's running an
instance of a database and a local
server for the for the local environment
and it's running a browser my webcam
microphone
yeah we're pushing it to its extreme
it's a lot of fun all right let's see
constructor name great all right that
should work and we're gonna run the
tests of course they pass there's none
there but what should we test
let's go boo here test the vegetable is
a class okay I want to see something
real quick arrow class X
this dot y equals the yeah what is type
of X function but we could do like
function dot constructor whoo here we go
oops
type of X dot constructor there we go
okay so in order to test if something as
a class we can do assert that vegetable
little type of vegetable equals equals
equals function and type of vegetable
dot constructor equals equals function
and then you put the message in here and
then we say vegetable is a class
why don't we use mocha instead of
writing them by hand you you're asking
the my favorite question ever because I
would absolutely love to be writing
mocha or tap tests but I just don't
think that's how this works for exhibit
particularly in fact we actually may be
using mocha underneath the hood but in
order for the whole curriculum to be
able to just kind of be generated into
any database anywhere like through like
JSON files and then be version
controlled via JSON files on I guess the
developers Quincy and bouncy like the
guys who like really like originally sat
down and put most of the original work
in I believe the other guy is what's his
name Berkeley yeah
Berkeley and Quincy when they like push
through it all this through they were
like this is how it's gonna be and
that's how it is it could definitely
change the future but this the style is
the same we have it's basically just the
word assert like you're asserting
something and then a true - false and
then a met a message there we go thank
you all right
message that's good now we need to
assert that the class word was used so
essentially well yeah okay I know I'm
just gonna do a code dot match guys I'll
just do class it's really that easy
test that other objects could be created
with the class sounds good assert I'll
just do like Const a equals new
vegetable it's true do something stupid
should we like to put like Apple yeah
well some fun with this well say
constant equals new Apple and then we'll
say return typeof a equals equals equals
object it's for equals it's too many
yeah I like that they'll say message I
should've kept that
other objects can be created using using
other instances of vegetable can be in
stand she ate it right but run node seed
we start the server
refresh the page unlock the code run the
test on the next one let's go alright
we're on to number 21 22 now so what
kind of coffee we drink in I think this
is just some house blend that my family
purchases just black I don't take
anything in it what's your what's your
kind of coffee I'm also I'm also a tea
guy I like green teas and different
herbal tea I'm not a fan of black tea
but it's uh yeah usually usually will
find me drinking tea during the day I
don't usually do coffee unless it's the
morning but someone got me thinking
about coffee so I had to go with it
getters and setters yeah ground at home
very nice yeah black black all the way I
had I used to do ground my own and they
used to have a French press but that's
not with me at the moment so back to
just k-cups at the mote right now cool
uh coding coding coding is our class we
called getters and Sutter methods yeah
we're gonna some object-oriented stuff
my favorite setters meant to modify the
value of an object private variable
based on the value passed in service
could involve calculations or even over
any appears that are completely
getwriter
set writer see I've never actually used
this before this is really cool someone
just asked what do you recommend me to
do when I get stuck depends how are you
getting stuck you just don't know how to
you know implement an idea or you unsure
about the idea in the first place I
guess a general answer would be mbn go
to the docs look up documentation I
don't stock overflows great don't always
have to go there immediately
sometimes just figuring out I spent I
spent I mean it's crazy to in a minute
but I've spent sometimes an hour or more
working through one little bug just
because it was some I was I had a Mis
name variable and I just kept
overlooking it so um you know I guess
another tip is take a break you know
look at it if you can't figure it out do
something else or go for a walk do
something get a glass of water come back
and I'm guarantee you you'll find it
within seconds strangely it just works
like that
so let's look over here so I believe
that this under underscore means private
they don't seem to go into that which
don't know why but guess it's an aspect
here oh yeah it seems like it notice the
syntax we're using to invoke the getter
and setter
they're not even functions we just uh
okay so guys this is cool sake
properties oh this is actually this is
actually a really fun example alright so
we're gonna create a class thermostat
how does this do we can use the getter
and setter in the method I don't know
constructor we just called temp
I'll call this Fahrenheit
but the temperature
we're on a sec I got to think through
this
hmm don't miss all right so
interesting so we're paying the thermos
is going to be a new thermostat at
seventy-six degrees Fahrenheit and then
we want to get the temperature is going
to equal thermostat temperature which is
going to return which is going to set
the temp variable to twenty-four point
four so we need to have so we're on a
sec I see okay so we'll do a get
temperature and this will return
oh we had your some math they gave us
the formula interesting they gave you
the formula calculate Fahrenheit wow
this is this is an incredible challenge
I see a question do I invest in Bitcoin
I do not I do not have a single penny
invested in any cryptocurrency Bitcoin
litecoin etherium and though I am very
um I like to say I'm pretty well
educated in the field and have spent a
great deal of time reading white papers
and reading into it but um it's just not
not something I feel worth investing at
the moment is also it shouldn't be
treated as an investment it should be
treated as a currency and currently it
is not so I don't I don't exactly
support the use of Bitcoin or at least
the investment invest that in Bitcoin at
the moment that's a whole other
conversation so let's see here are our
API is going to deal in fahrenheits so
this guy gave the formula for Fahrenheit
with Celsius but we're feeding in
Fahrenheit so we're actually gonna have
to reverse this formula guys we got to
do some algebra
this is actually hilarious I haven't
done algebra and way too long did you
get for going to college and finishing
your math minor way too early
all right we're gonna start off by
subtracting 32 and then multiplying by
five and then dividing by nine yeah all
right so it's gonna be five ninths times
the quantity Fahrenheit minus thirty-two
we're gonna equal Celsius so we're gonna
reverse that over here so we're gonna
say oh wait we're over we're down here
now we're gonna say C equals 5/9 times
the quantity F - 32 can i code if my
math is the worst one possible you can
definitely do web development HTML CSS
javascript a lot of stuff like that
could definitely be done without math
but if you're looking to go into
object-oriented programming or data then
you need math even even basic algebra
and a background in algebra with a
back-end then a little bit of discrete
mathematics and you'll be fine for most
programming but if you ever really want
to get into like data databases and like
you you really want to have a decent
understanding of slightly some higher
other level of math concepts otherwise
your program will be limited one aspect
to this those algorithms and data
structures if you don't have a pretty
good understanding of like precalc at
least and like Houck one maybe then
sometimes analyzing algorithms and
making things as efficient as possible
can be difficult but it's definitely not
you know impossible it can be done but
yeah it's usually why that couple
because they they go and hand-in-hand
really well together
all right put the Fahrenheit in there
now and then with that formula out of
the way we can say what are their fee
versus resources jerk man while I'm
doing for you code camp um I mean I
would recommend free code camp read
medium the blogging platform fine follow
blogs including the free code camp one
YouTube has a couple video guys I don't
watch any of them but I know they exist
and build side projects I always
recommend having one side project I have
two right now we talked about that
earlier today but definitely side
projects those when you apply what
you're learning that is even if you're
not planning on launching anything or
selling anything even if it's just like
something you using or you build it and
any of you archive it for forever the
application of building something with
the skills you're learning is
instrumental to your future success all
right let's do five ninths times this
dot underscore F - 32 and we're going to
set
oh wait I think I just did this wrong
this is killing me
no I did this right but setting it
you're gonna do this dot F oh but you
said it so the ape this thing
it's API it stays this Fahrenheit inside
it but when you set it or get it it's
always Celsius I see alright so with
that we're gonna call this C and now we
know actually I gotta go put that
calculation back s times 9.0 / 5.0 I do
that 2 over here and now
all right that should be a good enough
hint
Wow all right gasps oh let's do this
all right and then we want to try I'll
just do the type of thermostat equals
function and and type of thermo stat dot
constructor equals equals function I use
this is if you're interested in where I
learned this little trick this type of
and the type of itself I was actually
writing a asynchronous method for a
back-end library called fast Fi
and one of the lead maintainer showed me
that the best way to check if something
is a asynchronous function is that it
has a dock the da a dot then callback or
something along those lines and you can
check that just based on the way
functions are passed around within an
application
great we're gonna test already done a
test if a cast keyword was used so we're
saying that and test that other objects
can be created with this class all right
I'm gonna quickly copy the message I
used here though sorry
here we go
how do you want it how do we want to
test this oh yeah silly me so I was
gonna look at this co2 the future would
be like apples not a vegetable gonna be
like you're right it's not
Fahrenheit oh let's 232 see right well
know that that thing is working so we
can save return type well let's just T
and we'll verify that T dot temperature
equals equals equals 0 because 32
degrees Fahrenheit is supposed to be 0
Celsius
oh no it didn't save my work okay fine
I'll rewrite the entire class for you
guys right now
we need a function declaration here yeah
and this will return so this needs to
return
yeah
cease for Celsius and then and we'll be
able to say this dot Oh
Oh didn't get that semicolon in there
let's let me run the test their most
that
let me just in case this breaks again
makes me fresh that's not what I wanted
their term oh it's just your thermo yeah
we're on node seed and RS
for
victory yeah hi team oh yeah we did and
we've gone through twelve yes six
challenges we're gonna do our aim is
seventeen so five more to go it's been a
quite a quite a ride oh this one looks
like it has a test just it's not working
so we'll see in the past the function
required could be used to import the
functions and code and external files
and modules while handy this presents a
problem some files and modules are
rather large you may only need a certain
code from external resources the s6 is a
very handy tool Animas import with it we
can choose which parts of a module or
file to load into a given file saving
time in my memory consider the following
example imagine that math underscore
array underscore functions it has about
20 functions but I only need one count
items in my current file the old require
approach would force me to bring in all
20 functions with this new import syntax
I can bring in just the desired function
like cell using object to structuring a
description of the above code ah cool
there are a few ways to write an import
statement but the above is a very common
use case the white space surrounding a
function inside the curly braces is the
best practice it makes it easier to read
the important statement straight note
the lessons in this section handle non
browser features import and the
statements we introduce to the rest of
these lessons won't work on a browser
directly however we can use various
tools to create code out of this to make
it work in browser
yeah like babel and the appropriate
imports add the appropriate import
statement that will allow the current
file to use the capitalized string
function the file where this function
lives is called college string functions
in this same directory as the current
file all right well I would write import
capitalize string from yeah
got string functions it's that thought
well alright
what is it doing here it looks like
these never finished they're not the
Declaration which we call this valid
import statement
tima I love your icon the monkey is very
cute the choir is not defined
okay
this seems like an issue challenge seed
I am a little confused
so ask us for this do I have to use like
you strict is that no you strict
the T in the word thaw in the note
paragraph should be uppercase where ah
nice catch Quinn
so it seems like this in particular test
wants the require word and it's not
running without it this is not I don't
I'm gonna flag this one what number is
this understand the difference between
two between import and require this is
ok so require is not find so I don't
know why this is doing it but I have an
idea that it has to do with the fact
that we're trying to use like a import
statement in browser and it might be
something on the back end I don't want
to try to delve too much into it let me
just make sure it wants I was a putting
guy in there I'll probably just use G
and
they're asking for that anyway yeah sure
yeah team anything its back-end okay
well we wrote the test case that's
really all we need for that one so we'll
move on to the next one
keep pushing through see we only have
four more to go I think this is the one
they create an export fallback with
export default yeah I didn't write that
one there
yeah aluminous you're right that's a
good point second note paragraph also
has a typo let's see go back to this
we'll keep working through it
great no
cool that's that I'd like to take a
luminous good good catch Teemo and I
want to take a luminous --is point into
this because that is a very that that's
very true and that this seems to skip
right over that the only thing though is
what if we don't what if we're not using
a node a an NPM project and we don't
have node modules could the with the
import still work
I mean maybe we can make we could
probably write another note about it but
let me see so now that I've done that
let me write the note paragraph and then
we can go from there we can run the test
again and see if the the dot forward
slash fixes something I mean I don't
think it will because the require still
isn't being loaded right strong note in
most cases
oh hi Siri so as in most cases the file
path requires a
before it otherwise come a node well
look for a dependent or we'll look in
the node modules directory before it
otherwise node we'll look in the modules
directory first trying to load it as a
dependency great I think that justifies
that once we finish once I finished
writing pretty much getting the base for
all these tests done I'm making this
this kind of part of the curriculum like
usable we're gonna want some QA so if
you guys are pointing these things out
now we have 27 tests to go through could
use would love the help so but that's
step two let's unlock the code run it
yeah
alright that's fine this test isn't
running cuz it's having some require
issue I'll make note of that let's move
on to the next one though use export to
reuse a code block
let's code from our trials in order for
this to work though we must utilize one
of the statements that goes with import
known as export we want to want some
code function or variable to be usable
in another file we must export it in
order to import it into another file
like import export is a non browser
feature the following is what we
referred to as a named export with this
we can import any code we export into
another file with the import syntax you
learned in the last lesson here's an
example capitalise string export had
extra functions had expert variables
alternatively if you would like to
compact all your acts or statements into
one line you can take this approach the
other approach is perfectly acceptable
below are two variables that I want to
make available for others file of other
files use utilizing the first way I
demonstrated export export the two
variables oh so we can he just wants to
chords export written here in here
are we doing get rid of the eyes again
oh and throw in this time he has the at
least has semicolon on the back we need
to write in message
straight code foo up food guys know
what's on my mind is exported
great
same deal I don't think exports are
gonna work this seems like some sort of
challenge issue there it's not something
we're gonna try to solve this evening
maybe another video or someone else
doesn't know much coffee I drink I'm so
tired
yeah exports is not defined I don't know
why so we're just gonna add Sarina add
exports is not defined number 24 all
right
ever wrote these just forgot the right
way to write the tests suppose you have
a file that you wish to import all of
its contents into the current file this
can be done with the import star syntax
here's an example where the contents of
file named math bunches are imported
into a file in the same directory import
star as my math module from yep and
breaking down that code okay you may use
that any name following import as
portion of a well first typo is that I'd
like to inkling as is a very important
part the code
cool easy peasy import star as my string
module from
properly uses a code M for star as
syntax
alright export in one line should be
export in or export default export is
name and that why export does not make
any sense
aluminous I would encourage you to make
a create a new issue and reference these
challenges directly because you're
making some very valid points and I
don't want to take full credit for them
let me I can point you in the right
direction there I'm gonna keep going
through what we have but definitely
definitely for this export stuff
it sounds like they could use a nice
little update so on in case you don't
know just go to free code camp go to
issues new issue and just go for it I
believe you can also find the beta live
here so you could just go to the beta
after you cooking up that org map es6
and then use export to reuse a code
block make sure you copy this link and
go from there definitely be a great
thing to add to the project
I'm missing something here there we go
that'll fix that this test probably
won't work but we're not even gonna try
they know that well actually let me get
the error so import star as my string
module from so required not to find is
the same error for question number 25
oh yeah Timo I am nice catch
I'm watching I'm tracking my battery use
and stuff for my laptop make sure things
are going well and vs code is currently
using one hundred and sixty-two percent
of my battery which is why it's been
slowly dying all over you sitting here I
believe it's the fact that I literally
running a database inside of my editor
along with serving files the local
server so yeah let's move to the next
one we're almost done in the exper
lesson you learned about the syntax
referred to as a named export ah
luminous see this file has something to
do on export default this allows you to
make multiple functions and variables
available for you some of their files
there's another exports intact genes now
known as export default usually will use
a syntax if only one value is being
exported from a file it is also used to
create a fallback value for a file or
module here is a quick example of export
default you cannot use expert default
with our letter Const the following
function should be the fallback value
for the module please add the necessary
code to do so export default that wasn't
that hard alright same stuff this guy's
just got that so we'll just get rid of
his I and then add our message in here
so we'll say properly proper use of
export here any export fallback
I want to get the output error so I can
track that
this has the same exports not to find
error okay
oh my gosh we're on the last one forgot
to mark these downs one more in the last
challenge you learned about X for
default and deduces is important to note
that two important default export to
import a default export you need to use
a different import syntax in the file
example we have a function and that is
difficult that you fall export for
bottle malfunctions here is how to
import it the syntax differs in one key
place the import value is not surrounded
by curly braces default export okay cool
so as simple as going import subtract
from math functions yeah I'll run these
tests cuz we know they're gonna fail
this is a requires one so we're gonna
write number 27 here it's funny kind of
alternates we'll go down here guys we
did it we're at the bottom of the file
literally three hours later well six
things didn't work out at first
properly imports
export default function method here we
go hey let's do let's make sure
everything looks good we're gonna commit
this thing and wrap up it has been a
very very long live code session very
thankful for everyone that got to join
me today and learn a little bit about
what it's like to contribute to free
code camp alright great well missing a
little something here
semicolon all right we're not gonna
rerender for that that's about that so
let's wrap up one more time I'll walk
through it for the end quit everything
that you're doing quit turn off
turn off gulp run git status get status
will tell you what has changed you ready
get add and you just you can add a file
manually by typing the whole path or you
can just do the dot that adds everything
and then normally you would write get
commit m and then a message but because
free code camp is awesome we have this
terrific npm run commit command which
has an interactive commit thingamajigger
so we're gonna write test challenges and
we're gonna say es6 shall I would do see
what did we do before we did it now
we're doing C 17 through C 27 right know
this sorry this was C 21 through C 27
and the other ones runs get push origin
feature add es6 tests so I'm pushing to
my branch of free code camp which is
origin I when I do get I always make my
origin remote my branch and then my none
of my I use upstream and upstream refers
to the like the master or like the one
that like the developers created so like
for example free code camp free
Ocampo its a Shrieker camp is my
upstream repository so now that I've
done that we can go and check here we'll
see we already have a notification and
that means that this just got updated
and that's all twenty-seven challenges
tested and run through we still got a
bit of more work to do this was a lot of
fun and today just by going over here
with the emojis I don't know how many of
you guys are left in the chat but there
is anyone left I'd love to answer some
questions before we head out before I
head out for the evening
we'll say PR challenges I'm gonna say
update that comment we're gonna say
found issues with challenges number 23
through number C 27 know what that was
not what I wanted to do
nope come on work with me here
require is not defined equals produced
for challenges 23 25 27 and then we had
exports is not defined produced for
challenges 24 comma 26 great alright
guys I am exhausted from coding for this
long but I'm very happy I did it I'm
glad having you all here this has been
quite an experience feel free to reach
out with any questions ever about
open-source about free code camp about
coding in general I'd be happy to answer
them I believe my twitter is in the
description so you can find me on there
you can also reach out to me through the
beginner chat for free code camp and
yeah with that I'm gonna say thank you
very much this is Ethan Arrowwood
signing off hope to see you guys in the
future